this year's Nobel Prize in Chemistry is
about tailoring proteins for the
benefits of humans and our planets
proteins our best friends they are
everywhere inside us
they help us move see think to the left
you see an enzyme that is a protein that
can speed up chemical reactions by your
catalysts to the right you see an
antibody that is a protein that I can
grab onto foreign objects and protect us
from invaders
this year's laureates harnessed the
power evolution to make even better
proteins that can be used to catalyze
chemical reactions in a sustainable way
and to treat diseases they developed
methods that combine advanced knowledge
about how proteins work with a bit of
good luck to be able to find improved
variants beyond what we may guess that's
a very smart trick it takes the best of
what we know and ask the experiment to
tell us even more this year's Nobel
Prize in Chemistry unifies two aspects
of protein evolution one half goes to
Francis Arnold for the directed
evolution of enzymes and one half goes
to George Smith and Gregory winter for
the phase display of peptides and
antibodies here we will now first learn
about phase display George Smith was
born 1941 in Norwalk United States for
his college education he took a very
wise decision and went to have a for
college a warm and nice liberal arts
college in Pennsylvania
he then went to Harvard for his PhD in
Cambridge United States the other
Cambridge as we call it in Europe he is
now an emeritus professor at the
University of Missouri your Smith
developed face display this is an
ingenious method that provides a
physical link between genotype and
phenotype what's inside and outside the
method has become extremely useful for
deriving knowledge about binding
determinants to derive better binding
proteins and also to improve proteins in
many other ways including stability
tourists may find I welcome you on the
stage we are very much looking forward
to hearing your lecture
[Applause]
when this award was announced on October
3 my friends who were actual chemists
were surprised to learn that I was one
too
and that brings up the question of what
is a chemist of course we might try to
use anecdotal evidence to recognize
chemists by their behavior for example
two chemists are toiling away in the lab
when a funeral procession approaches on
the road below and chemist one stands at
the window with this hand over his heart
until the funeral progression of
procession has passed and afterward
chemist two says I am in awe of the
reverence that you show to the dead and
chemist one says well she was a darn
good wife my darn good wife Margie Sabol
is very much alive and sitting in the
audience as
[Applause]
as our our Don gher darn good sons are
darn good daughter-in-law my darn good
brother and sister-in-law my darn good
sister and brother-in-law and some darn
good colleagues some of whom will figure
in this lecture because they were
directly involved in the experiments
that I'm about to describe and by the
way in case you have seen the movie the
wife I would like to assure you that
Margie didn't invent phage display
actually I think it may be a little
doubtful that phage display was an
invention I know that it looks like that
from the outside but from the inside
from my point of view phage display was
a series of small incremental advances
from the knowledge that I had the ideas
the published findings and so on that my
science community had made available to
me and that are the nutrients of my
science community so my science
community is the global overlapping
community of molecular biologists of
evolutionary biologists of immunologist
protein chemists phage biologists it's
etc so I feel that I'm accepting this
award as a representative of my science
community and I say my science community
because I belong to the community not
because the community belongs to me and
so perhaps a better way is to say that
it's our science community and it's our
science community in a broader sense as
well because the society as a whole in
so many myriad ways sustains our science
communities including mine the school's
educate our children some of whom go on
to be a
the professional members of science
communities they go to our universities
for their continuing education including
my University the University of Missouri
that not only educate our our children
but also sustain our local science
communities and also our national
institutions such as the National
Academy of Sciences the National Science
Foundation the National Institutes of
Health in the United States the Medical
Research Council in in Great Britain
that that promotes science that do some
science themselves and that's that
support science fiscally so let me
introduce phages phages are viruses that
infect bacteria this is the phage the
class of phage that phage display was
developed with they're called
filamentous phage because of their shape
long and thin like a filament phages in
general have many different shapes but
they have this in common that they have
an outer coat an outer coat of protein
made up of phage coat proteins and that
coat surrounds or in cases the phage
genome the phage chromosome that has the
phage genes and the particles are about
one micrometer long that's about half
the length of the cells they infect but
only six nanometers in diameter so they
are extremely thin compared to their
length I've mentioned chromosomes genes
and proteins and let's just be clear we
give you a crash course in molecular
biology let's be clear the relationship
among them so the DNA chromosome is a
long chain of the four nucleotides a G C
and T in a specific order or sequence
and a gene is a segment of that
chromosome that specifies or encodes as
we say it a polypeptide so a polypeptide
is a long chain of the 20 natural amino
acids again in a specific order or
sequence that is specified by the gene
and polypeptides in general will fold
spontaneously into their natural
three-dimensional shape there nate's
that's the native protein that has the
proteins biological activity I would
like to introduce one more term that
will appear and that's peptide so a
peptide is a short chain of amino acids
and in the context of this lecture
peptides are encoded by short segments
of DNA in genes back to phage I would
like to briefly outline the phage
infection cycle very simplified and I'm
drawing the phage about 3 times bigger
than its normal than its size relative
to the bacterial cell that it infects so
the first stage is attachment of the
phage to the cell that it's going to
affect and within minutes the phage
chromosome is intruded into the interior
of the cell without killing the cell and
over the course of the next hour or so
the phage chromosome replicates so now
there's many chromosomes inside the cell
and the phage proteins that are
specified by the phage genes including
the Koch proteins gene coat proteins
accumulate in the cell and ultimately
the cell extrudes progeny viruses
progeny phages in great numbers perhaps
a hundred within the first hour
filamentous phage are a little unusual
among phage in general in that they
don't kill the cell they in fact so the
infected cell continues to grow and
divide although at a lower rate than
uninfected cells and continues to
extrude progeny phage meanwhile these
progeny phage are able to
in fact any uninfected cells in the
culture and so soon all the cells are
infected so let me outline what this
means in numbers so if we start with a
flask with one liter of culture and
about say 10 10 to the 11th cells and
one phage particle and shake that
vigorously overnight we end up with the
next day with about 50 times more cells
and about 10 to the 15th phages so 10 to
the 15 some of you may not be familiar
with that number so 10 to the 6 is a
million 10 to the 9 is a billion 10 to
the 12th is it is a trillion and 10 to
the 15th is a thousand trillion or a
gazillion and and that's and this is a
tremendously tremendous advantage of
phages
as study organism because they can
produce they can be produced in enormous
numbers very cheaply and very simply so
faint display so I've done with phage
now and we're getting getting onto phage
display phage display have this origin
at the end of my sabbatical leave with
Bob Webster in the biochemistry
department at Duke University Bob this
is a picture of Bob recently cleaning up
after hurricane Florence earlier this
year at this retirement home on the
North Carolina coast but he was a major
investigator of the biology of
filamentous phage and I was a newcomer
to the field and that's why I came to
his lab for for the for my sabbatical
and much of my research was focused on a
particular Co protein gene the co
protein encoded by that coat protein
gene was at the tip of the virus the tip
of the phage particle
it's a multifunctional protein
part of it is buried in the particle
innocent is is essential to the
structural integrity of the part of
particle but the rest of it is exposed
out in out to the surrounding medium and
plays critical roles in the infection
process and it was also known through
many channels that this protein was
flexing the exposed parts were flexible
that they could be manipulated that they
didn't have a set tight structure and
that suggested to me at the time that it
might be possible possible to insert
foreign pieces of DNA into this coat
protein gene and into the part of it
that coded for the parts of the protein
that are exposed on the surface and as a
result the extra peptide it would make a
longer gene encoding not only the
regular coat protein but also a little
extra piece and that extra piece of the
protein the peptide that that extra
piece corresponds to would be displayed
on the surface so down the hall from Bob
Webster's lab was Paul mode urges lab
here he is getting his chemistry Nobel
Prize three years ago and he was
studying a protein called eco r1 at the
time and he gave me the gene for eco r1
an antibody against the eco r1 protein
so here's what I did with it I cut out a
piece of the equal r1 gene and inserted
it into that coat protein gene and the
expectation was that the resulting
construct the resulting modified phage
would have a piece of the eco r1 protein
of pep talk from eco r1 protein encoded
by that piece of eco r1 gene on its
surface at the tip so this is the first
phased a phage display construct
and I should say that from now on in the
lecture I'm going to simplify the
cartoon representing phage display
constructs so I'm going to eliminate
representing the chromosome and the host
coke protein gene and just have a
colored rectangle representing the
foreign DNA insert that's in that Co
protein gene well I told you that that
Paul mode which gave me the antibody
against that protein so I should say
that this construct this phage was still
infective but when I mixed it with the
antibody against eco r1 protein it
blocked infection presumably because it
bound to that piece of eco run protein
on the surface and prevented an
infection and this is the first
indication that the phage display
concept seemed to be feasible it seemed
that it was possible to display foreign
pieces of foreign proteins or pieces of
proteins peptides on the surface of
phage I was very excited about this and
it's very likely that many of you don't
understand what was interesting about
that and so please wait I will try to
make it there but I was really
interested in so when a week or so later
when Margie and I drove back home to
Missouri I soon swung my research
program over to developing the phage
display idea and luckily a darn good
colleague Steve Parmley showed up as a
graduate student in the lab and Steve
had two projects one project was to
develop a really practical phage display
vector a vector that would make it easy
to insert foreign pieces of DNA into the
coq protein gene having minimal effect
on the on the function of the phage that
have still be infective still be able to
be produced and that wasn't an easy
project yet he tried many there were
many tries some of which didn't work out
so well so one of them was Pig 3c
Figg three seed didn't work too well at
least it was certainly wasn't the best
construct but it soon became a mascot in
the lab and Steve is going to take this
over to the Nobel Museum as one of our
artifacts and and the the second task
that Steve took on was developing
affinity selection and I know those
words don't mean anything to most people
in this audience and that will be
explained presently so just as Steve
left the lab another darn good colleague
Jamie Scott came as a postdoc and Jamie
Scott was the first one to make a large
random peptide library and I'm gonna
describe that in a minute too and to use
Steve's affinity selection process also
to be described presently to select
peptide from that library and I would
just like to mention a third darn good
colleague that's Robert Davis Robert
Davis came to my lab just about the same
time as Jamie as the chief manager and
technician and he was a wonderful and
wonderfully productive technician with
just marvelous intuitive lab sense and
he had many tasks and one of them was
that he was our DNA core so what it
meant in those days that he's
responsible for all the DNA sequencing
in our lab we calculate conservative
conservatively that he sequenced a
million bases of DNA using the
old-fashioned radioactive technology and
if you've ever used that some of you are
old enough to abuse that you know how
laborious Lee how laborious that is and
how technically demanding it is so I
hope Jamie will forgive me
not using the work that she published in
1990 as the illustration of random
peptide libraries and affinity selection
I'm going to use a work that involved
the model system that came to our lab a
few years after she left because I think
it's easier to explain so this this was
the S protein system that was brought to
our lab by two graduate students from
Yale
John Ladd Barry and David Schultz and
it's the S protein system so the S
protein system derives from research of
Fred Richards at Yale in the late 1950s
he was studying the structure of the
enzyme
reiben nucleus which is represented here
in three dimensional form and he showed
that the proteolytic enzyme subtle
eyesand would split
ribonuclease into two pieces one piece
was the s peptide that was only 20 amino
acids long and the other piece was the S
protein which is a hundred and four
amino acids long and those two pieces
could be separated from each other and
when you did that
neither piece had the enzyme activity of
ribonuclease but when you added s
peptide back to s protein it bound to s
protein and restored enzyme activity
this is the S protein system and we
regarded it s protein as kind of a like
a stand-in for a receptor maybe a
receptor involved in a disease or
something is kind of like a pretend
receptor because it was we could even
buy it commercially and maybe we could
think of s peptide as the natural ligand
for that receptor say a hormone or
something and maybe when that hormone is
over produced and it binds to the
receptor you get the dreaded s protein
disease and let me assure you this is
fake news this is just pretend but this
is the way we've thought of this as a
model system so I'm just to introduce
random peptide libraries and affinity
selection
in the context of an experiment was done
in the middle 90s by jinan you in my
laboratory as a graduate student in my
laboratory so she had this s protein
receptor but she could get impure form
and she also had a random peptide
library so let me describe what that is
a random peptide library is a huge
collection of phage clones and each
clone differs with regard to the groups
with regard to the foreign DNA insert
that's inserted into the co protein and
these are short DNA inserts and the
particular library they that she used
had inserts or were long enough to
encode 15 amino acids and they were
random DNA sequences and as a result
random 15 amino acid peptides are
displayed on the surface of the phage at
the tip round blue peptides sharp gold
peptides squared green peptides etc and
actually her library had 250 million
different clones and I assure you that
the random DNA inserts didn't have to be
synthesized one at a time that would be
an impossible task they could all be
synthesized together in a single vesicle
in one operation and also they didn't
have to be inserted into the co protein
gene a one by one that all this
insertions could again be accomplished
in a single vessel in a single operation
so here's a picture of the library in
that bottle there are 10 to the 15th
pages representing 250 million different
phage clones each one displaying a
different 15 random 15 amino acid
peptide so here was her task her task
was to find out of that 250 million
peptides very rare peptides that would
happen to have the ability to bind to
that receptor to that s protein receptor
you can see this would be a really hard
task how are you gonna go through 250
million phages one at a time especially
as they're all mixed together but you
didn't have to do that because of the
affinity selection procedure that that
Steve had previously worked out so let
me describe a Finity selection first the
receptor was immobilized on a solid
surface it was the plastic surface of an
ordinary plastic petri dish next the
library or a portion of it representing
every one of the clones many times over
was poured into the petri dish and
sloshed around for an hour or so
and during that sloshing around period
if there was a peptide that had good
affinity for the immobilized receptor
the peptide and its and the phage that
it was attached to would be captured on
the surface of the petri dish whereas
all the other phages the vast majority
in the library would be floating free
and that allowed those floating free
those unbound phage particles to be
washed away leaving just the particles
you want and that they could be released
and you're home free but you're not
because the released particles were
released in tiny tiny numbers so there
two reasons for that
one is that any phage clone that
displayed happen to display a peptide
with high affinity for the receptor
would be a tiny minority of all the
original phage clones there and
furthermore the the capture processes
not very far from 100% efficient maybe
more like 1% of efficient if you're
lucky but it doesn't matter because
remember that these particles are
infectious by simply by infecting fresh
bacterial cells you can produce them you
can amplify them up to trillions or
gazillions so this is the peptide using
the one letter abbreviation for the
amino
since that that gene on selected in her
experiment and although I just say it's
very important to point out that never
did we use any information about s
peptide in either the synthesis of the
library the construction of the library
which was done by collaborators in Japan
who made the library available to us and
certainly had didn't have s peptide or s
protein in mind and nor nor wasn't used
in the finiti selection nevertheless I
think it's it's instructive to compare
the sequence of the selected peptide
with a sequence of s protein the so
called natural ligand well they match in
five positions and four of them are very
important the ones in red because they
happen that happens to be matches in
precisely the four amino acids of s
peptide that were known structurally to
be deeply buried in s protein when s
peptide binds s protein so these are the
residues of s peptide that are
responsible for the tight binding and
the selected peptide matches them so in
a certain sense this is really kind of a
successful experiment and I I think I've
explained enough about it
I just want to make a generalization
that this artificial selection in the
petri dish
mimics in some important respects
natural evolution in the living world
natural evolution depends critically on
diversification generating varieties of
a variance of living things and the and
in phage display what corresponds to
that is making enormous phage display
libraries with great diversity of
peptides displayed secondly evolution
depends on natural selection to favor
some variants and disfavor others and so
to in phage display affinity selection
greatly favors
some peptides over others on the basis
of their affinity so it this is a very
simplified kind of selection that the
experimenter controls and decides for
the experimenters own needs and this
diversification and natural selection is
the engine of adaptation in a natural in
in the natural world evolution in the
living world and so generation of great
diversity and affinity selection leads
to peptides with desired activities so
let me summarize this again is the
library and by applying her specific
selection protocol to that library she
was able to discover in that library a
cure for s for the imaginary s protein
disease but what end would there be to
other marvels that could be selected
from the same library using other
selection protocols Marvel one marvel -
who knows what what end there is to this
and indeed several other members of our
science community have filled bottles
like this numerous bottles like this
with other phase display libraries of
novel and imaginative design and from
those libraries some remarkable marbles
have been selected some of which you'll
hear about from one of my co laureates
and our next speaker Greg winter thank
you very much
[Applause]
sir gregory p winter was born 1951 in
leicester united kingdom he got his PhD
1976 at the University of Cambridge
the first Cambridge and he's now a
research leader emeritus at the MRC
Laboratory of Molecular Biology in
Cambridge he realized early on that face
display could become a very useful
method when you work with antibodies
this would be a tool to derive their
high affinity antibodies for any targets
that you wish with strong determination
he spent all the effort required to make
it possible to display antibodies or
antibody fragments in functional form on
the surface or the filamentous phage so
that he couldn't fish out the good
members from libraries sir Gregory
winter I now welcome you on stage thank
you
[Applause]
well good morning ladies and gentlemen
it's still just the morning Sara thank
you for your introduction may also thank
you and your colleagues on the chemistry
committee and their advisers for all the
hard work they had to do that ended up
with this with me getting a share in
this prize so thanks um I would first
like to acknowledge and thank my family
it gives me great pleasure they're all
here today and we'll have to listen to
me for a whole half an hour without
interrupting me or saying dad we didn't
want a lecture on it so I would also
like to thank the academic institutions
that I Ardath now this is going to start
to thank the various academic
institutions who've supported me
throughout my scientific life in
particular the MRC the Medical Research
Council's laboratory of molecular
biology in Cambridge the Medical
Research Council Center for protein
engineering in Cambridge and Trinity
College Cambridge all the same
Cambridge's I would also like to
acknowledge the key role of a startup
company Cambridge antibody technology
fourth time I've mentioned Cambridge in
the work that I'm going to describe I'd
also like to thank some individuals
I hope they recognized themselves from
some years back I'd particularly like to
thank John McCafferty who was the first
to show the display of functional
antibody fragments on phage I'd also
like to thank Alan first for his hand in
a number of things but particularly when
he was director of the Centre for
protein engineering for accommodating
the greater part of my group as it was
developing the phage technology
and all the others on the side who are
probably the most important because they
did the work they did the work at
different times they all had key roles
and they are the anonymous we that I
shall refer to during the talk finally I
would like to acknowledge Richard Lerner
and his group at the Scripps Research
Institute although we were certainly the
scientific competitors at that time
their activities complemented our own
and actually confirmed our own faith in
our work it actually helped us persevere
through many technical difficulties
because if we we knew that if we didn't
manage to do it they would so first of
all you had a tutorial on phages I'm now
going to give you a tutorial on
antibodies um antibodies are part of our
immune defense system they defend us
against infectious agents such as
viruses and bacteria they're raised by
the immune system in response to
infection or vaccination an IgG antibody
as shown on this slide is a large
y-shaped molecule it's got two arms and
a stem it comprises two heavy and two
light chains of linked protein domains
in this case it's the white and the red
the heavy and light chain variable
domains which are at the end of the arms
come together to form a protein scaffold
of beta sheet which I've marked here um
that's surmounted by six loops these are
these red loops mark numbered one to six
which are responsible for binding to the
antigen and in binding to the antigen
they can block the process of infection
in addition the antibodies stem here is
able to recruit the immune system to
kill the infectious agent to which it's
attached now the variability of these
Antron binding loops is created through
rearrangement of different germline
segments of DNA during B cell
development in heavy chains it's created
through random combinations of three
segments the so-called VH D and J
segments as marked on the slide each of
which has multiple members so you get
tremendous combinatorial diversity by
throwing these germ line segments
together in the light chain it's created
by random combination of two sets of
gene segments in addition where they
join there's editing takes place and
further diversity can occur during
during the DNA rearrangement process as
well as random pairing between the heavy
and light chain domains as the heavier
light chains are rearranged
independently so after DNA rearrangement
each B cell which I've got here so this
is before rearrangement after
rearrangement it encodes a unique
antibody on its surface so the
rearrangement process leads to
expression of antibody on the surface of
the B cell as the DNA rearrangements
proceeding in parallel and independently
in many B cells
this creates a library of B cells each
with a different antibody on its surface
if the displayed antibody encounters an
antigen the B cell is stimulated to
differentiate and it can do two things
it can differentiate to become a plasma
cell which essentially is a factory for
production of soluble antibody against
the cognate antigen that that antibody
is recognized alternatively it can
become a memory cell as mock here where
it where the antibody genes are
subjected to random mutation within the
cell
on further encounter with the antigen
the memory b-cells compete for antigen
and those displaying mutant antibodies
which have got the highest binding
affinity a favored for further rounds of
differentiation
this leads to an antibody response that
improves with with a Reese emulation
with with antigen it's a process known
as affinity maturation so in summary the
immune system is a simple evolutionary
system at its heart is the b-cell
it's a phenotype a genotype a firmly
linked it's a sensor genetic display
packaged with the antibody displayed on
the outside of the cell to encounter
antigen and the genes encoding the
antibody within now although nature
developed antibodies to protect against
infectious disease man has further
developed and evolved them for the
treatment of non infectious disease such
as inflammatory disorders and cancer
man-made antibodies can be used for
example to block the biology of protein
receptors and ligands such as they're
involved in inflammatory disorders or
cell growth or even t-cell activation or
they can be used to kill target cells by
recruiting the immune system to attack
it's the development of antibodies for
treatment of non infectious disease
that's revolutionized the pharmaceutical
industry and what this slide shows is
the is the top selling drugs in 2016
previously the pharmaceutical industry
was dominated by chemicals but what we
can see here I've marked in red in among
those top ten those antibody products so
actually the pharmaceutical industry in
the top selling products is now
dominated by antibodies we've got six
antibodies and the number one antibody
is an antibody called Humira which i
will come back to later these antibodies
are mainly used for treatment of
autoimmune inflammatory diseases and
cancer the the technologies to make such
antibody pharmaceuticals required
several years of inventions and
developments it started with the
mention of hybridomas biases on Milstein
actually also at the MRC Laboratory of
Molecular Biology in Cambridge in 1995
they immunize mice with target antigens
such as human cancer cells the spleens
were harvested and the responding
b-cells were immortalized by cell fusion
the hybrid cells or hybridomas were then
screened to identify those making
monoclonal antibodies against the target
antigens although this technology
generated many useful research reagents
against human proteins and cells the
mouse monoclonal antibodies were seen as
foreign and when injected into patients
they this compromised the use in fact it
would leave two life-threatening
reactions at that time an T but attempts
to make human monoclonal antibodies
against cancer cells proved impossible
not least because the immune system has
tolerance mechanisms that prevent it
making antibodies against self generally
this is fortunate where these mechanisms
break down it generates terrible
autoimmune disease by the mid-1990s
solutions for making antibodies
therapeutics began to emerge through the
application of protein engineering this
is a branch of genetic engineering which
the genes of a protein are altered and
the encoded proteins are expressed in a
host cell the first solutions here
involved creating map it creating what
we call simple chimeric antibodies in
which we take the entire antigen binding
regions at the end of the mouse
monoclonal antibody that for example
could be against a cancer cell and we
transplant the entire region into a
human antibodies the human antibody is
marked white so this antibody is
two-thirds human one-third Mouse and
should therefore perhaps be better
tolerated when put into patients then
came humanized antibodies down here in
which the antigen binding loops were
grafted from the
mouse scaffold the speeder sheet
scaffold with the six loops were grafted
from the scaffold to its human
counterpart
now as the inventors of humanized
antibodies which are up to 95 percent
human origin we argued that such
antibodies might in practice be regarded
as synthetic human antibodies as in any
case these loop regions differ between
one human antibody to the next
experience has actually borne this out
humanized antibodies are well tolerated
in the clinic and account for the
majority of antibody pharmaceuticals on
the market but at the time we weren't
actually so sure that the human immune
system wouldn't somehow sniff out the
taint of mouse that's in those loops and
it might treat them as foreign you know
I have a very anthropomorphic view of
molecules I think you need to think
about them like that and I was very I
was very uneasy about it despite my
logical arguments that they were just
the same as human antibodies so we were
very receptive to an opportunity to make
fully human antibodies that emerged from
a technical advance one of the the
rate-limiting steps in making chimeric
antibodies these are the 1/3 human 2/3
Mouse was the isolation from the
hybridomas of the genes encoding the
antibody variable regions in theory this
is straightforward in practice actually
it's it's a pain in the neck and to
simplify matters we thought we might be
able to use the polymerase chain
reaction to amplify and clone the genes
from the hybridomas now in the
polymerase chain reaction target regions
of DNA so exam arch one here can be
amplified by repeated cycles of
extension of two flanking primers by DNA
polymerase and by repeating the cycles
one can get a dramatic amplification of
that DNA and clone it
but since we didn't know what the
sequences of the genes were in any
particular hybridoma it wasn't clear
that we could design pcr primers that
would work on any hybridoma what we did
was to compare lots of different
antibody sequences and we spotted
regions at the ends of so if we look
here this is a heavy chains heavy chain
sequences we look at nucleotide
conservation at the end we could see
regions which are a hundred percent
conserved with rip with with the regions
where they're not conserved and we
thought that maybe by playing around
with experimental conditions we might be
able to find a set of PCR primers that
could amplify any Mouse region from
hybridoma
so we set ourselves that task evolved a
lot of fiddling about it was the early
days of PCR but in fact we we did find a
set of primers that worked for most
hybridomas we could actually amplify the
genes from most hybridomas we were given
and we later developed a similar set of
pcr primers for amplifying human
antibody genes now these primers made it
so much easier to clone antibody v genes
and it and this it is that that
presented the new opportunities for
example instead of isolating the mouse v
genes from antibodies tape from
hybridomas why not amplify them directly
from the spleen of an immunized Mouse if
we express the inchoate antibodies
perhaps we could find the ones with
antigen binding activities this offered
a simple alternative to hybridoma
technology for making mouse monoclonal
antibodies but better still if we could
make libraries of human antibodies we
might be able to bypass immunization and
find ones with binding activities to
human self antigens as we need for
therapeutic use so we were excited by
the potential but first we had to find
an expression host we looked at bacteria
it had recently been shown that function
t body fragments could be expressed
in the bacterial periplasm we took
libraries of antibody fragments from
wells we took we took libraries of
antibody genes and express these as
fragments in bacteria those genes came
from immunized mice and we soon
discovered fragments with antigen
binding activity now by this time we'd
become aware of a similar approach being
explored by the group of Richard Lerner
at the Scripps Research Institute who
had similar results but both of our
groups were completely unable to detect
antigen binding without the use of
immunization so clearly our our
screening methods weren't really
powerful enough certainly if we wanted
to make human antibodies we therefore
look back at how the immune system
manages to select antibodies as I
explained earlier at its heart is the B
cell could we find a B cell mimic we
thought of many possibilities display on
mammalian cells display on bacteria or
even display on bacterial viruses but it
looked like I would need some more staff
but I didn't have the money or the space
to accommodate them at that time I met
David chisel and John McAfee from
Amersham international who due to an
error in the counting process is we're
in the process of being made redundant
they were excited about the possibility
any job really they were excited about
the possibility but they were
particularly Explorer excited by the
potential of the library technology and
we wondered about forming a startup
company to do that but it was a struggle
to get funding but finally I succeeded
to an old friend
Geoffrey grig he'd set up a star he'd
set up a startup company peptic in
Australia that was mainly backed by the
mums and dads of Australia but it also
seemed he backed by a out called the
horse-racing fraternity um I had to go
and meet the shareholders on a yacht in
Sydney Harbour and I remember one of
them saying I'll give Greg the money
let's see how the boffin trots which was
so peptic in fact in the end became the
major shareholder in Cambridge
anybody technology David chisel and John
McCafferty joined and John came to work
in the laboratory of molecular biology
and we decided to focus our energies on
the beast you've heard about in the
previous talk
the filamentous bacteria phage so some
four years earlier george smith had
shown that filamentous bacteria phage
was capable of displaying peptides and
that the phages display bearing the
peptide epitopes on the phage gene
through protein could be selected by
binding to cognate antibodies so could
this phage serve as an mimic of the b
cell instead of peptides could we
display folded antibody fragments on the
phage and in this slide I've actually
used a different representation of phage
this is what I call our Dalek
representation which I much prefer to
the very long phages this is like
something out of Doctor Who and we
rather liked it so we've been using this
very simplified representation so what
we have here is the antibody genes on
the inside of the phage and the the
antibodies the antibody fragments
so-called single train efi fragments
where we have a linked heavy and light
chain variable domain on the outside
they're fused to the phage to the gene
three protein so then we tested the
recombinant phage for binding to the the
hen egg white lysosome which was the
antibody corresponding to these V genes
we've taken a monoclonal antibody
hybridoma
and we cloned it in here and we found
out these phage is using analyzer assay
bound very selectively and specifically
to hen egg white lysozyme but not for
example to turkey lysozymes they're very
specific and it everything we looked
very good so we now mix the phage
antibody with a large excess of
wild-type phage and attempted to enrich
the phage antibody to show the
demonstrates the other work of George
Smith and and Parmelee the affinity
selection process and we found that we
could select this phage by multiple
rounds of affinity columns in fact on
one pass we could enrich the phage or
antibody phage a thousandfold
and by growing the enriched phage and
passing it down the column a second time
we can enrich it a further thousandfold
which means we've got a millionfold
enrichment over two rounds of selection
and in principle using three rounds of
selection you could get a billion-fold
then you could go up to George's
gazillion if you just increase the
number of of cycles so we were very
pleased really that these folded
fragments could express on phage because
it certainly wasn't clear to us that
they would but it turned out to be what
the system seemed to work beautifully
so we then turned to making antibody
expression libraries are on phage and
the the library was a so-called random
combinatorial library it was a type that
had been described earlier by the
Scripps group in which a library of
antibody heavy chains is combined
directly with a library of light chains
usually from the same immunization and
this process so for this process can be
expected to generate the original heavy
light chain combinations of the b-cell
that had originated from as well as
entirely new combinations and this is
shown on this slide so let's take a very
simple case of two B cells with encoding
two different antibodies one with a red
and white light chain and the other one
sorry one with a red heavy chain and a
white light chain and the other one with
a green heavy chain and a black light
chain so if we clone out those genes and
we shuffle them all up we end up getting
four possible combinations two of the
original and two new ones the red blacks
and the green whites now as you increase
the number of b-cells that you that you
use you you decrease the probability of
finding the original combination and you
increase the probability of finding new
combinations so for example if you took
a thousand b-cells in principle which
were all different in principle you get
a million different combinations by
combining them of which a thousand would
be the originals and 999 thousand would
be would be new combos so we were very
interested in new combos because
actually in if we were to take antibody
genes from here
we need we knew we needed to generate
new combinations of heavy and light to
generate new binding activities in order
to be able to I to find things in there
that would bind to the self-antigens we
knew the immune system would have
deleted all of those original
combinations that bound to the self
antigen so for our first library we took
the V genes from the spleen of a mouse
immunized with a hapten a phenol phenol
ox as alone now you may wonder what a
hapten is it's essentially just a
chemical entity that's coupled to a
protein and it's been used by
immunologists for many years just to
study how the immune system works and it
simplifies the the understanding of of
of how the immune system works and the
kind of antibodies that you get to
different to different targets now from
a library of about a million clones we
obtained faint binders with a range of
different heavy and light chain pairs
and we couldn't distinguish the original
from the new ones but some had binding
affinities comparable to the very best
hybridomas in other words in the order
of 10 nano molar these were hybridomas
made by says our Milstein from that same
spleen because we ran the thing in
parallel we cut the spear in half he had
one but we did the other the affinities
he could get were as good as the ones
that we could get which was a great
irritation to him but the technology was
looking very promising with our second
library we faced up to the altogether
more difficult problem of making human
monoclonal antibodies without
immunization after actually quite a few
technical improvements I didn't have
time to go into we created a a larger
and more diverse library this time from
the white cells of human blood donors
from a library of 10 million phage
cleanse sites it tenfold bigger than
that one I've described earlier from the
immune Mouse we managed to isolate
binders to many different antigens
foreign antigens human self antigens and
but these have binding affinities in the
micromolar range and those affinities
are too poor to use
for therapeutic use so we knew we got to
improve those affinities so I'm just
going to focus on the left-hand side of
the slide we decided to improve those
finishes
let's follow what the immune system does
so the immune system takes selected
b-cell clones and it subjects them to
random mutation and further rounds of
selection with antigen so for example we
took a a phenol oxygen binding phage
antibody from our human library with a
rather modest micromolar affinity and we
grew it in a bacterial mutator strain
and after multiple rounds of growth and
selection an increasingly stringent
selection we managed to get mutants
crawling out at the end with affinities
a hundredfold greater now in the low
nano molar range which is quite
comparable to the affinities of mouse
monoclonal antibodies made by repeated
immunizations of the same antigen in a
mouse we could even construct a
genealogical tree and we've got some
some attempt to show this here in which
you could see the sequences at week by
sequencing all the mutants that we got
at different rounds we could identify
four sequentially acquired mutations
each of which was responsible for
lifting up the affinity and giving us
this this this great increase in binding
affinity the right hand side of the
slide describes a shuffling approach
which I'm not going to go into but it's
an alternative and simpler way of
creating faster way of creating affinity
improvements it's not enough where it
wasn't enough just simply to create
mutations we also needed to find ways of
selecting between between those stages
with different binding affinities and to
do this we apply it increasingly
stringent affinity selections so for
example using longer wash times so all
the weak binders washed off and the
strong binder stayed stuck to the
support the other possibility was use
low concentrations of antigen so here
what I've shown here is on the left is
we've biotinylated the antigen let it
equilibrate with the phage and then
capture the phage bound to the antigen
using streptavidin beads
and that also showed that we could in
with this we could apply that and fish
out selectively those phages with the
higher binding activity but there was a
confounding issue which is touched on
here and that is that we discovered we
hadn't really expected this whereas in
George's case that the phage generally
it all the antibody heads express a
peptide but in the case of the
antibodies we found that a lot of our
antibody heads were chewed off so a
phage antibody might have between 1 and
5 heads each species actually presenting
different binding visitors to a solid
support which greatly complicated our
selection of those with the highest
binding affinity so we reduce this
problem by a an approach devised by Jim
wells in which what he did was he I
think he died for a slightly different
purpose in which we created what so
called monomeric phage with fewer
antibody heads so actually what we end
up doing is is infecting that's right we
encode the antibody fusion on a so
called phage mid and we use a helper
phage to supply the other gene three
subunits so we end up with antibodies
which have a single antibody on there or
otherwise they're completely bald now
the bald ones don't bind to anything so
that's very easy so you just end up with
those which are bearing the antibody so
as well as developing libraries of V
genes from these B lymphocytes we also
have been exploring the creation of
synthetic V gene libraries by cut by
combination of the underlying V gene
segments building blocks now the
advantage of synthetic antibodies is
that the diversity of the library is
known and we can tune it to order but at
that time the sequences of most of the
human V genes were not were not known
and if we wanted to use this as building
blocks we had to find them so we started
mapping and systematically cloning and
sequencing all of the human build
antibody building blocks
and then we assembled them to create our
largest and most diverse phage library
of more than 10 billion clones including
almost all of the human B gene segments
so we now got a huge library and we
could select that so we assemble the
library these featured segments as
indicated on the left and then we
selected that library and against
foreign and self-antigens and we now
found antibodies with binding affinities
in the nano molar range quite comparable
to the finishes of hybridomas in fact
really by using these very large
libraries we avoided the need to do so
much affinity maturation so the great
thing about this is from a single very
large library you could fish out
antibodies to all kinds of different
targets now in parallel with our work at
the MRC the startup company Cambridge
antibody was working with commercial
partners to develop human therapeutic
antibodies their most spectacular
success was the development of the phage
antibody a dilemma map which is
otherwise known as Humira which is
targeted against TNF alpha an
inflammatory mediator and it's used for
treatment of autoimmune inflammatory
diseases such as rheumatoid arthritis
psoriasis or Crohn's disease now when we
started the work on a dilemma map the
random comment or a light the random
comment or libraries of human antibodies
just weren't large or diverse enough we
couldn't find anything in there that
would be useful so we had to try a
different strategy and we decided we
would we would try and bootstrap
starting with a mouse antibody so we
have a mouse antibody which i've marked
in red and we took this for example here
the mountain sorry the mouse heavy chain
cerebral region we paired it with a
library of human light chain so you end
up with this hybrid half human half
mouse was selecting on antigen and we
did in fact find we got some bind
by doing that and now what we did was we
combined that selected human chain here
with its partner chains from from a
human library and essentially selected
again so in a couple of steps we'd
managed to create a a human antibody
essentially from a mouse template so I
wouldn't call it a humanized antibodies
no trace of mouse in there other than we
have built this human antibody using
this mouse template so it's essentially
rather like the saw grandfather Zacks
business you know the handle you know
that by my grandfather changed the head
and and my father changed the handle and
you know it's my grandfather's axe well
you know it's completely different the
whole thing is completely different it's
a different entity altogether now other
than adalimumab came with antibody
technology and late later MedImmune into
which it was incorporated a focused on
creating very large libraries usually
not synthetic but from human donors of
about 100 billion clones and they end up
getting high affinity antibodies from
those and I'm grateful to Janos born of
MedImmune who used to work in Cambridge
antibody before they were taken over for
the information on this slide so the
upper portion shows the range of
pharmaceutical target classes including
targets here which which MedImmune has
made phage antibodies to and you could
see a whole range of growth factors
chemokines ion channels receptors GPCRs
cytokines protease inhibitors and
peptides and on the lower portion of
this slide down here um you can see
those phage antibodies that are already
on the market so they've gone through
the whole process of clinical trials and
testing and there there are 60 more
still in clinical trial are still moving
through the system and so in conclusion
you can see that this technology
enough of these antibody repertoires
with the filamentous phage has actually
proved extremely powerful way of
harnessing evolution and is delivering a
great new wave of antibody medicines
with that thank you
[Applause]
Francis Arnold was born in 1956 in
Pittsburgh United States she got her PhD
in 1985 at the University of California
at Berkeley she is now active as a
professor at California Institute of
Technology in Pasadena also in
California
Frances Arnold pioneered directed
evolution of enzymes she used her
engineering skills to make this method a
most versatile tool for developing bio
catalysts for new environments and for
new tasks she has made a strong effort
to make this planet a better place the
enzyme she develops can be used to speed
up chemical reactions in a sustainable
way making less waste in a cleaner
process we call them fantastic
biocatalysts now Frances Arnold I
invites you to the stage to deliver your
thoughts
thank you I'd like to thank the the
Royal Swedish Academy of Sciences the
Nobel Prize Committee in Chemistry my
family many of whom are here my friends
even more of whom are here and
especially I'd like to thank my former
and current students and I know there's
a group of you here because it's really
their contributions that I'll be talking
about today I'm my engineer I have been
in awe and mesmerized by the chemistry
of the biological world for some time
because it's this incredible diversity
of transformations that gives rise to
all the beauty and functionality that we
see in the natural world the complexity
of the products that nature makes and
when you think about how she can
assemble these products with ease and
elegance and remarkable efficiency from
simple renewable abundant starting
materials to me that's a real
inspiration for chemistry of the future
now who does this chemistry it's the
enzymes these remarkable marvelous
molecular machines that catalyze all the
reactions in the living world almost all
the reactions in the living world and
that our DNA encoded now I'm also in awe
and inspired by the enzymes but also by
the process that nature uses to create
them and in fact that nature uses to
create everything in the living world
evolution
it's a remarkable diversity generating
machine it's a simple algorithm of
mutation and natural selection that
gives you a recipe for adaptation for
optimization for innovation and has
created all the life that we see around
us starting from a
Universal common ancestor a simple life
form more than three billion years ago
now I wanted to build new enzymes and
protein engineers like I was in the
1980s we struggled mightily with a
simple problem and that is we didn't
understand and we still don't today
enough about how a DNA sequence encodes
function in order to be able to reliably
design a new enzyme that's why I turned
to nature's process so here's the
problem even today we can read DNA we
can write DNA you can just email a
sequence off to your favorite supplier
and you'll get it back in the mail we
can edit DNA CRISPR casts we have all
these tools but what we do not know how
to do and this is the problem that I
took on thirty years ago is how do you
compose it it's like a Beethoven
symphony the code of life it's intricate
it's beautiful but we don't know how to
write like that but nature does you have
this process so we can think of all the
proteins that exist today in fact all
the way back to the Universal common
ancestor as this set of proteins that
are relevant to biology biologists this
is what you study this little green
place because that is but an
infinitesimal fraction of the possible
proteins we can think of this universe
of all possible proteins as a playground
for the future this is where I want to
explore and I want to explore here
because I think the solutions to many of
humanity's biggest problems lie in this
space now this is a challenge of course
because this space is vast it's bigger
than the universe the number of
particles in the universe by many many
orders of magnitude
this remarkable short story by Jorge
Luis Borgess the library of Babel
describes for all practical purposes an
infinite library of all possible books
and the librarians there are in despair
how could I if I want to search this
universe of sequences which is like all
possible proteins but I know that most
of those possible books encode nothing
at all they're just gibberish these
random combinations of letters don't
compete with pumping oil out of the
ground for example how could I search
this library and find something
meaningful so this is a tough problem
because if you look at this space it's
so big and we've heard some very big
numbers in these experiments gazillions
well I cannot search for gazillions I
don't have tend to the gazillion
graduate students or even ten to the
ninth graduate students and if we look
at for a large protein now we've gone
from peptides to antibodies which can be
quite large but we go to something like
an enzyme that space of possibilities is
enormous if you make a single mutation
to a typical protein you have thousands
of ways to do that you start making too
and you have millions of ways you make
three and it just grows exponentially
we cannot search this the space just
without thinking a little bit about the
process now John Maynard Smith helped me
address this problem in a marvelous
paper that he wrote published in 1970 my
favorite one and a half page paper and
he said consider proteins in an ordered
space where every sequence is surrounded
by its neighbors that differ by one
mutation and he argued that if evolution
is to occur and he believes it does and
I think most of us here believe that
evolution happens functional proteins
have
be distributed in this space so that any
functional protein something you can
scrape off your shoe is surrounded by
other at least a few other functional
proteins forming a network may be sparse
in the space where most sequences are
gibberish forming a network where
evolution can walk along and that's
exactly what proteins have done for the
last three and a half billion years
they've accumulated mutations one at a
time primarily to create what the
proteins are today now of course I want
to make better proteins
I want to make enzymes that will solve
human problems so let me add more and
more dimension to this and that is the
fitness the performance how an enzyme
performs a new job and that's defined by
me in this set of experiments and we can
think of this now as an optimization
problem on a fitness landscape now in
the 1980s we knew very very little about
the structure of this landscape
it could be rugged and if it's very
rugged than most mutations of
deleterious and send you into a crevasse
of non function and evolution is very
hard in that case on the other hand if
it's smooth and John Maynard Smith
helped argue that it has to be smooth in
its dimensions for us to be here to talk
about it then you can use simple
optimization processes now science like
all human endeavors is an evolutionary
process right it builds on what is there
and we recombine different Peet's pieces
from different places and a lot of
interesting things were happening in the
1980's you've heard about some of those
and in the early 1990s for example
Manfred eigen was talking about
experimental molecular evolution and
Jerry Joyce was evolving RNA in the
laboratory directing the evolution of
RNA jeremy Knowles showed us that
beneficial mutations and proteins could
be accumulated
Stuart Kaufmann was talking about the
theoretical fitness landscape searches
and then for me Dan Dennett a
philosopher gave me wonderful words and
framework for the ideas that I was
trying to work on and all of these came
together in a simple process now the
difference between my experiments and
those that you've heard about is that I
don't have an affinity selection that
lets me search through a million or ten
million or a billion different molecules
we have to measure them one by one
because you get what you scream for in
this business and if you're looking at
it enzyme you need to measure what that
enzyme does maybe we can test a few
thousand things or a few tens of
thousands of things most of those
mutations are deleterious so this meant
that we had to be very careful about how
we were going to carry out this
optimization making just a few mutations
at our time maybe one at a time randomly
in the molecule scream carefully to
measure the small effects that you would
expect to get from a single mutation and
then if you wanted something that was
very different from what you started
with and believe me choosing that
starting point is important because you
don't get a racehorse from a donkey so
you choose that that's a very rational
thing if you want something quite
different from what you start with then
you have to iterate you have to
accumulate those mutations over multiple
generations and this gave us an
experimental process that has proven its
value so if you start with your donkey
and and most enzymes are pretty good
Nature has done a good job optimizing
them for their job but if you start
asking it to do a new job for me they're
less enthusiastic let's say and that
Fitness drops dramatically but on this
smooth Fitness landscape a simple
optimization of accumulating mutations
over multiple generations can reoptimize
it for the new job
that worked from the 1980s that we
started this culminated in this first
paper published in 1993 where Kevin Chen
showed that we could adapt an enzyme to
what was considered a highly non natural
environment fat it was so now not
natural that many biochemist told me oh
you can't do that it won't work
an enzyme will never work and
dimethylformamide
in fact they don't like it at all but
what we showed is that with a few
mutations and doing this process you
could convince it to work just as well
in 50 or 60 percent DMF as it was did in
its natural environment in 1995 I met
him stemmer shortly after his DNA
shuffling paper was published we met at
a workshop at the Santa Fe Institute and
I was taken with his vision he he
introduced this idea of sexual
recombination so this is another search
strategy for evolution seems to work
pretty well there's a lot of diversity
you get by recombining your DNA with
somebody else's and Pym talked about
this is a molecular breeding process and
I often use that when I present my work
now sadly PIM passed away in 2013 but he
started a company that pushed a lot of
this technology mine and his out into
the world and as a result of their work
at maxsa j'en and many many other
laboratories this directed evolution
process has has created enzymes that you
will find in your laundry detergents
that are used to manufacture
pharmaceuticals that are used in all
sorts of different industries today I'm
very proud of those applications none of
which I'm responsible for but that's the
nice thing if you provide a basic
framework that's simple and this is what
engineers like to do make it as simple
as possible then the whole world will be
able to use it but we learned some very
interesting things about in
in the process of doing that of course
they will adapt rapidly we didn't know
this at the time we didn't know how many
iterations how many mutations it would
take to get a new function out of an
enzyme or to make it function in a non
natural environment or take a new
substrate and those came rapidly we also
learned that we are a long ways away
from being able to design them because I
knew this process would be useful back
in the 90s because we knew it was fast
but also that the solutions that you got
were so surprising mutations happened
all over the protein 2030 angstroms away
from the active site where no one could
explain them much less predict them so
here we have this marvelous optimization
mechanism and that's what I've told you
about you take a a biological enzyme and
you can optimize it and change it for
different functions so now I'm going to
fast forward into today so that I can
end with the future I'm interested today
not in the optimization so much although
that's very important but actually how
does evolution create novelty how could
you create enzymes to catalyze reactions
you cannot even find in the biological
world or at least we haven't found them
yet you cannot go to a database and find
an enzyme that catalyzes your favorite
reaction how could we import reactions
even invented by human beings a hundred
years of creative chemistry how could we
import that into the efficiency of the
biological world in genetically encode
whole new chemistry and at first I
thought that would be a really hard
problem because we all know enzymes are
so beautifully designed they positioned
their functional groups to catalyze a
reaction and stabilize a transition
state and how do you create a whole new
active site it's a very conservative
process what I just described to you
making one mutation at a time but that's
the wrong way to think about it because
nature is making new enzymes all the
time usually to break down your bill and
billion
antibiotic but usually in response to
pressures that humans have placed on
this planet so here's a great example a
potent herbicide that we've been dumping
into the environment onto our fields for
more than 60 years was first thought to
be non biodegradable then all of a
sudden some enzyme figured out how to
dechlorinate atrazine giving a rich
nitrogen source to the organism that
invented it and it spread all over the
world this is evolution in real time
evolution in real time every time you
see antibacterial soap we're causing and
pushing evolution but it's happening
quickly so how does this happen
how do you get evolution in real time
well it happens that enzymes already
have those capabilities
they're like graduate students you're
selected for working long hours at low
pay and you can do that but maybe you
could also play the piano or do dishes
if you had to if chemistry was no longer
a viable field for work you could go and
switch into something else what enzymes
are just like that any enzyme that
exists today has promiscuous
capabilities that evolution uses as a
fuel for further invention and if you
can find those promiscuous capabilities
I'm the trainer of molecules I have to
see those then you can use this simple
turn the crank
presto results process of directed
evolution so let me give you an example
I love the cytochrome C's because here's
a family of enzymes that Nature has
diversified to carry out all sorts of
interesting chemical reactions and many
of you are familiar these nature's uses
one or a set of closely related highly
reactive intermediates to do this and
presumably through this process of
mutation and selection has diversified
this family now we argued in looking at
this that wow this looks a little bit a
little bit like human invented chemistry
if you could convince a cytochrome p450
to create a reactive
Media that has a carbon these are
reactive carbons in the active site make
an iron carbonate maybe you could
convince it to transfer that and do
human chemistry like turn double bonds
into cyclopropanes or insert that carbon
and into an xh bond this is not known in
the biological world it was invented by
human beings but if we provided the
right synthetic environment think
atrazine right a new niche for the
enzyme and this tool of directed
evolution perhaps we could create
enzymes for these new human things so it
becomes a question can a heme protein
create these new reactive intermediates
and there was some evidence that that
would be possible but then the hard part
would it take that instead of using it
to to itself up would it transfer that
to a second substrate so now you've got
to have two substrates coming together
in a enzyme that's never seen these
before and if you can see that little
bit of activity does it evolve five
years ago we asked these questions and
I'll just give you one example of much
more recent work that we did in fact
these do do carbon transfer we've
created a whole bunch of carbon transfer
aces and one of the ones that I love to
talk about is one that does chemistry
that even humans have a really hard time
doing making highly strained carbon
cycles like by cyclo butane which is a
transformation not known in the
biological world and even in the
chemical world the world of human
chemistry is very difficult to do and it
requires precious metals so iron
earth-abundant
iron was never known to do this but
chi-chan showed that he could make
cyclopropanes we have more than 50 kcals
per mole of ring strain in these
structures and that by providing a
carbon precursor to this the enzyme
would form the reactive carbon transfer
it to that and the furthermore it
evolves so he discovered chitin
discovered an enzyme sitting in our
refrigerator I have a tremendous
collection of interest
ding him proteins and he just said can
you do this as a promiscuous activity
then he showed he could evolve it over
multiple generations to become a
reasonably efficient catalyst but even
more wondrous is that he could further
train the enzyme to do it twice so if it
hangs on to this reactive cyclopropane
in the active site he can now add a
second carbon so you blow off nitrogen
with this that drives the formation the
carbon you can now add a second it might
by cyclobutane pure diastereomers you
only make one of the four possible
diastereomers because the enzyme creates
the environment where this remarkable
chemistry can take place
furthermore the enzymes can make lots of
by cyclobutane now as far as I know
nobody wants by cyclobutane if anybody
wants them please let me know but these
are interesting interesting molecules
that really have evaded human chemistry
but hear an enzyme just learned how to
do that in a few generations and they
happen inside living cells so you do
this chemistry just by providing the
substrates to bacteria in a in a culture
and they'll see you out enough of these
so that we can get we can assign the
absolute stereochemistry let me give you
another example consider bonds that are
unknown in biology here we have silicon
an element that is so abundant on our
Earth's crust and has never been found
bonded to carbon in the biological world
there are no carbon silicon bonds in
biology some people have wondered why
that's the case I'm not going to answer
that question but now they are found in
biology because if you go to my
refrigerator you can find proteins for
example from this hot salty pool in
Iceland from an organism that grew there
and that protein if you just search
through these that protein will take a
carbon precursor
and this silane dimethyl phenol silane
and insert the carbon into that silicon
hydrogen bond and make new organosilicon
compounds just a wild type protein no
one ever asked if nature could do it of
course these are not naturally abundant
compounds but nature is capable Nature
has the inherent capability to do or
igano silicon chemistry for tea
turnovers that's as good as the best
human-made catalyst just a natural
protein 97% of nantou selectivity oh and
by the way I just point out this is a
cytochrome C and it is so stable so
stable you can boil it even a chemist
can use it it's so stable it just looks
like a powder and it works beautifully
for this chemistry the native function
of this cytochrome C is electron
transfer and in fact if you know
anything about cytochrome C you'll be
puzzling whoa how does this happen
because the active site where this
chemistry takes place if you look at the
crystal structure of this protein you
see that the active site is all filled
up with protein it's the iron is fully
saturated all the ligands from the
porphyrin ring and the axial ligands
above and below just fill up the active
site so if you roll your little ball
over the computer you find a big fat 0 4
active site volume but Nature doesn't
care about your calculations because
this protein is perfectly happy to do
this chemistry and our pictures are
simple pictures of proteins don't do
justice of what's actually happened
not only does it do this chemistry but
this protein also evolves so that if you
make mutations near the active site over
three generations you can evolve the low
promiscuous activity of the wild protein
into something that out becomes dozens
of times better than the best human
catalyst just turn the crank give them a
little bit of sugar
and the proteins will evolve and it
works inside of bacterial cells why is
that important the bacterial cells will
make your catalysts and make millions of
versions of your catalysts for the price
of sugar so if it's DNA encoded and
these are all just you put the gene into
the bacteria if it's DNA encoded you can
just grow all the catalysts that you
want and mutate it a million times for
the price of sugar and here I show you
an example where for example you could
choose between putting that carbine in
on silicon or a nitrogen and if you've
evolved the catalysts it chooses only
the silicon so you get chemo selectivity
enantioselective 'ti all done by the
bacteria now when this story was
published went all over the world
because everybody said we're making
silicon-based life that wasn't the case
I don't have time to go into some of the
funny things that came about it but
apparently nobody actually read the
paper they only read the title of the
paper so it went around the world and
mutated the story as it went around the
world and and it gave my group a lot of
fun laughter reading the Twitterverse
interpretations of how we were creating
silicon-based life but it works in life
and you could conceivably build silicon
into living systems now that you have
genetically encoded chemistry you could
also learn how the protein learned how
to do this you could get the structure
of the protein and in this case we see
that the structure has changed
dramatically we have a loop over this
active iron that has completely flipped
out into solvent there were three
mutations that were made in this protein
it's caused this loop to flip out and
opens up a volume a pocket here that has
sufficient volume now to accommodate a
large number of different substrates
and do this chemistry extremely
efficiently dozens of times better than
the best catalyst that was ever
published by a human being if you can do
it with silicon you can do it with other
atoms as well and so for example
recently a year later we we just
published excuse me the incorporation of
carbons into boron H bonds and yes there
are no boron carbon bonds found in the
biological world and here's a bond
that's very much favored by temas a very
versatile system organ abhorrent but you
can take an enzyme or a protein like
cytochrome C and just turn the crank so
you're starting to get a little bit of
the pattern here you discover a little
bit of activity you have this wonderful
optimization problem process and we can
find by starting with the zero
generation wild-type protein and
evolving over three generations you now
have something that when you use it
under optimal conditions is 400 times
better than the best human catalyst for
the same reaction does it with
earth-abundant iron and you can of
course also change the selectivity
tuning the catalyst for the chemistry
that you're interested in I'll just
point out that in the biological world
one criticism we face if we want to do
biocatalysis is that oh you can't do
what I can do I have great chemists at
Caltech who can do and create materials
that biological world can't do but I
hope that's going to change because I've
just shown you even though biology is
limited to the bonds that it can make so
carbon for example is often found bonded
to nitrogen or oxygen or sulfur a little
bit to the halogens a few other things
lots of lots of hydrogen of course but
there's vast portions of the periodic
table that it we have never found a
biological system to do and I just
showed you in the
of two years we've added two whole
elements to biologies repertoire so you
can now build carbon boron and carbon
silicon scaffolds in living systems and
of course then do further chemistry on
that in metabolic pathways so I would
like to leave you with this idea for the
future because I'm I'm really excited
about now but even more so about the
future of this science that we have this
incredibly powerful design algorithm
right it works at all scales from
molecules to ecosystems and it not only
optimizes but it can innovate and it can
do it in real time and in the chemistry
world what that does is open this
opportunity basically to take down the
barrier between the natural chemistry
and human invented chemistry and just
import all those human inventions into
the biological world just sit there and
I sit there and read chemistry papers my
students read old Jack's journals and
they say wow I bet I could import this
reaction in and I haven't shown you many
of the other ones that they've been
successful in doing but this is an
exciting thing I think for the young
people people because by marrying these
different fields it's it's like you're
in a goldmine of possibilities that you
can now genetically encode and make much
easier some of your favorite chemistry
and I'd also like to leave you with this
idea that the biological world is is
wonderfully diverse there is a bazillion
proteins out there just waiting to solve
your problem and nature knew this right
the Internet of Things now now it's the
Internet
of living things that's been
crowdsourcing problem solving for more
than three billion years and if we learn
how to use this to our benefit we can
move into a much more sustainable future
and make our fuels and chemicals using
biological systems
so I'd like to leave you with this idea
that we have AB universe to explore we
have a spaceship for exploring that
universe it's called evolution and I
want to thank the very large number of
people who've worked with me over the
years at Caltech a big fraction of them
are shown in this picture they came for
one of my big birthday's a couple of
years ago and once again I thank them
and I thank you for your attention
[Applause]
Frances Arnold George Smith and Gregory
winter thank you all for wonderful talks
and I now welcome all three of you up on
the stage to take all their flosses
[Applause]
okay